what's going on reject nation first off
this guy needs a haircut
secondly uh john and i we did an
interview with two of the directors and
one of the writers
from raya and the last dragon the movie
it's great by the way
highly encourage you guys to go ahead
and check it out we talked about a lot
of things in this interview actually
from the animation the action the
villain
there's chapters in the video if you
guys want to hop around also do want to
give you guys a heads up we did
actually shoot a movie reaction for this
we are
just beginning to edit right now that's
what i'm saying guys go ahead check
around the last dragon it's a wonderful
film later this week you'll get to see
john and i
laugh and cry yup it's an emotional
experience
enjoy
hi we're greg and john with the real
rejects how you guys doing
good we're good nice to meet all of you
um we watched this movie last night and
uh you successfully made two grown men
cry
a lot of tears by the end of this movie
we were very
very much moved because this is aimed
right at us we're the target demographic
clearly right in the pocket yes yes
exactly
towards the end in the middle a few
different parts
definitely the the finale moment yeah
the light the for the last
20 minutes 30 minutes we must have just
been in tears the entire time and then
yeah it just
wouldn't stop it's pretty common it's
pretty common with us yeah
if there's any constellation we're not
immune to it either i mean we still
do the same thing when we watch it so
yeah you just think i'm going to dawn
when it happens it's
really through your own tear stream
why are you crying you're the one that's
supposed to be so cold
out of us three don is for sure the
coolest so
when whenever we we got to the core and
he was like
really opening up about it we knew that
we'd hit on something special
we were very impressed especially by the
by the finale moments and actually for
kind of our kicker off question one
thing i did
want to ask was actually in regards to
the villain namari uh
who's not really like a full-on
antagonist i'm not sure who would even
be the best one to answer for this
question but she ended up being our
favorite character
quite early on in the movie and i don't
know if that's most people's takeaway
yet
but what was the approach with fleshing
this character out because she's not a
full-on villain she's
actually got one of the biggest arcs in
the whole movie
really wanted to make sure that when we
wrote you know created this character
she was a
a nemesis that that we could sympathize
with much like killmonger for
black panther you know like you
understood uh that point of view and in
a lot of ways
namari is raya except for the big
differences raya met
sisu and if there's a version of this
movie where namari found sisu first and
she would have brought the gems together
and had to convince
raya to get along but obviously she is
just a
badass so it's hard not to love this
person with like the guns that she has
and the attitude that she throws you
know
we actually had to pull back uh to be
honest and i don't even think we told
the story yet um
yes exclusively
big big spoiler um because we we sang we
had the same journey with the mari you
know we had these expectations of
wanting to really flush her out and not
be a one-dimensional
sort of antagonist but i i think we
actually almost took it too far because
there's a scene in the movie
all right where we cut back to fang and
the shot it starts the dragonfly and
then you see these drone right
and then we go to fang that scene
actually was namari
uh returning to fang and fighting her
way through
a bunch of drones saving one of her own
people yeah yeah
yeah and see exactly saving her own
squad there uh and it was really cool
boarded by
co-director john ripa everything he
bores is beautiful and we fell in love
with it and then we watched the movie
and we realized
oh we can't we it's too early to be you
know team namari
you know we got to be team raya here for
a while yeah it was really hard but we
had to cut that out of the movie
it was so good it was so good it was bad
but there was an
entire past we were just like hey we
can't let people fall in love with
nemari that much because we're gonna
start rooting for her and then like
our movie is gonna get really confused
[Laughter]
i thought it was brilliant i i we were
really really impressed with it and also
we're suckers for good action scenes
i mean obviously like dawn with your
work in big hero 6 that was some of the
best
animated action i've seen from disney
but the action here especially
um i'm actually half asian so i felt
quite represented watching this movie
i want to add and i grew up on like a
lot of hong kong cinema as well
but i'm curious because like when this
trailer came out a lot of people were
referencing things like
avatar and tomb raider and then when i
watched the action scenes i was flashing
back more to the kung fu flicks i i uh
flicks i grew up on what were the
inspirations you guys were drawing from
were there actual specific like
action movies or action stars
types of martial arts well i mean i got
to be the
like fight consultant on the film and
you know we we definitely
on real yeah martial arts which were
awesome jax a lot mutai
our knees and uh traditional vietnamese
wrestling so it's like
based on real things you know when it
comes to the shaw brothers stuff it was
all wire work stuff
for us we wanted to really base it on
like real world physics
so they're more athletically gifted like
all these moves are possible
and so that was something really
important and then we came to like you
know visual inspirations that i kind of
you know recommended for the animators
to see it was like tony jaw
it was angbok it was the raid it was
chocolate so it was definitely
they got to see some real good you know
southeast asian martial arts to kind of
just draw
their inspirations from yeah it was it
was really to put it bluntly it was
really badass
it was probably the best hand-to-hand
combat in any disney movie we've ever
seen for sure
and i think just just for that like
there's a lot of inspiration that we're
pulling from
the kinds of movies and the kinds of
filmmakers that we like the most so
there's
there's a lot of that coming from queen
but there's also a lot of the classic
90s epic
one movie particular i'm gonna let don
name that movie because it's
his reference and we made fun of him for
bringing it up in every single meeting
every day for a year
you know it was raiders raiders of lost
ark it's one of my favorite hell yeah
yeah
you know obviously there's some real
like you know like when she's getting
the
the gem out of the skeleton hand you
know that's very much like andy
it's almost a perfect action film you
know uh raiders of lost ark and
and uh it's just almost a perfect film
but uh it did come up a lot in our
discussions to the point where i think
these guys rolled their eyes they're
still rolling their eyes
when it comes off it was all of that and
then i think to top it off we really
wanted to
uh infuse moods like some contemporary
filmmaking choices so we looked a lot at
taika waititi and it kind of grew right
and
like some of these some of these danny
boyle some of these filmmakers that use
like really stylized visual storytelling
so i think that the combination of all
these sensibilities is hopefully what
results in something
unexpected when you think about this
movie you come in expecting one thing
and hopefully it surprises
you a few times yeah it sounds like you
guys pulled a lot from
live action influences especially
i think our lighting team our uh
cinematography team
some of the camera work some of the lens
choices some of the rendering like
really
everyone stepped it up i mean don who's
been at disney for
longer than any of us three uh
don has been there for a long time and
he took on the role of our our
our mentor and we we look up to him with
respect
sorry we didn't know these guys earlier
it's like in all stories the mentor
always dies so
i'm going obi-wan here in america i
don't know a little bit of a flip though
you're already official just laughing is
every interview we've been starting by
saying you know don's been there for a
long long time
[Laughter]
it's really just it's it's a sign of
respect more than anything but anyway
he's been there for a long time
and the amount of times that he looked
at us and was just like i've never seen
anything like this in any of her movies
uh like the amount of action the visual
quality of the image
so to be able to surprise the people who
are doing this every day and have been
doing it for a long long time i think
was a really
good reward for us mission accomplished
yeah absolutely
really quick because i know we only got
a couple minutes here how did you then
approach
balancing all these different action
influences and all this you know
swashbuckling
with i have to imagine a lot of research
went into the culture behind the movie
and even with the shifts in animation
style that we really loved
how did that all kind of come together
well the research was foundational
and you know we came on movie about a
year and a half ago but a lot of the
research had been done even previous to
that because this project goes back uh
six years in total so um i think there
were three research trips
uh to many different cultures and
uh countries in southeast asia over the
course of that six years
and you know a ton of experts
from the cultures themselves that they
met on these research trips became our
southeast asian story trust so they
consulted on
everything from clothing to music to
architecture and and that was absolutely
huge
and then the mixing of stuff i mean some
of those scenes like the stylistic
scenes we knew we wanted the prologue we
thought okay that'd be great to use
shadow puppetry that was like
preordained and kind of thought through
and you know a special team was you know
built to to actually pull that off
the other ones kind of happened just i
don't know we were looking at
scenes and kind of said hey wouldn't it
be cool if we
changed the style thinking that we would
be told no you know like our visual
effects supervisor would look at us and
be like
you know uh but they're like okay cool
let's try some stuff and
so early on big hero 6 one of the
animators did a
just an early test and did a look
similar to that on this test not saying
it was going to be the look of the movie
that just said something cool
and i just had that in the back of my
head and and we pulled that out and
looked at it and
everybody thought that's cool let's go
for something like that and
they pulled it off as wise and grizzled
as don may be
he does say wouldn't it be cool a lot
and i think kind of like the secret to
like a lot of his like don's
movies in particular that keeps
surprising us when he comes a big hero
to moana to this
there's a lot of like wouldn't it be
cool if and then people in disney just
love getting in it's like yeah it would
be cool
and they just followed it through but i
do give credit that's for don for
letting us you know
uh push wow that that was one of our
favorite parts was different animation
styles infused throughout with the
flashbacks especially
our time is up a qui don carlos thank
you guys
don carlos it sounds like a name in
himself thank you guys so much for
your time and last thing i'll say carlos
blind spotting was my favorite movie
that year should have won best picture
just gonna throw that out dude all right
thank you guys